[Applause]
all right
you know
it's Friday
it's Friday which means first let's
welcome tonight's guests this bear
doesn't poop in the woods probably oh
it's got a special report Brett Bear
she's the only Kennedy we want running
for president and driving host of
Kennedy on Fox Business Kennedy
all right
her book's a number one bestseller at
doorstops.com Fox News contributors
and before he leaned on it it was just
the regular Tower of Pisa my massive
sidekick and the nwa's World Heavyweight
Champion Tyrus
yeah
now that's what I call an All-Star panel
in your face
got my bear golf shorts on outside here
trying to get a game in all right before
we get to some news stories it is Friday
so let's do this
Greg's leftovers
hmm yeah it's leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading these
so if they suck I will dismember a
writer in front of you
yes
here we go the national champion Georgia
football team will not be visiting the
White House this year the coaches say it
wasn't because of Any policy but that
they just couldn't understand President
Biden's directions
Robert De Niro welcomed his seventh
child this week
which means his girlfriend will now have
to change two diapers
[Applause]
yeah clap now you wait 20 years
a homeless man named Fred innocent
that's great
definitely his real name he was charged
with a hate crime after he took a dump
on a pride flag outside of Manhattan bar
but since his name is innocent
technically they have to let him go
I felt like that joke could have gone in
a better Direction
anyway
he would have been unhoused if it wasn't
a gay pride flag but it was a gay pride
flag so it's homeless
there you go
last week CDC director Rochelle wilinski
officially stepped down for her own
guidelines before returning home she has
to quarantine for 10 to 14 days
a new survey on job satisfaction has
found that workers are happier than
they've been in decades
that's
said one woman
how's that uh dental hygiene school
coming along
I look awesome
[Laughter]
a new poll reveals Donald Trump is
leading Joe Biden by seven points when
told the news Biden said he wasn't
worried he just needs a touchdown and a
two-point conversion
an Ohio Judge has ruled that a trans
woman did not commit indecent exposure
in a female changing room after the
defense argued that body fat covered the
entire genitalia area
oh my God
proving sometimes it's less embarrassing
to just plead guilty
I'm 41 announced this week they're
breaking up after 27 years together the
news was so big both fans were
heartbroken
why are we going after some 41 what did
they do to us
reports claim pelotoners are calling
over 2 million exercise bikes because of
a defective seat post
sadly this will leave countless
Americans with nowhere to hang their
clothes
boy
a website is offering to pay people a
thousand dollars to binge watch all of
the Fast and Furious movies
this despite the fact that the US has a
strict policy Against torture
a man staying at a hotel in Nashville
woke up at 5am to find the night manager
sucking on his toes
when asked to comment he said I'm just
glad I fell asleep on my stomach
finally
finally finally this week President
Biden's approval rating hit a
jaw-dropping 36 percent prompting Secret
Service to change his code name to Bud
Light
well that's it
so with their ratings in despair they
put Trump on the air and now they're
taking heat for having him in the hot
seat which means it's time for
[Music]
fear behind our garbage on screen
my father worst thing you've seen
perhaps we change our routine
[Music]
might as well
[Laughter]
nice well done
all right
CNN is still recovering from their super
magnificent totally amazing town hall
with President Trump this week true it
was every bit as successful as a street
festival in Pompeii
for you history fans during it everyone
saw the former president mop the floor
with moderator Caitlin Collins in front
of a home crowd who welcomed him like
Genghis Khan on Father's Day
he had a lot of kids yeah he did good
Pete had just beat not by much but poor
Caitlyn first they gave her six months
with Don Lemon and now this it makes you
wonder did she run over her boss's dog
at this point she should just go into
hiding and change her name back to Bruce
I'm Caitlin
anyway this was uh this was her before
the town hall
and this was her after
[Laughter]
CNN didn't fare much better
CNN came out looking so bad actually
people are calling them the CNN of news
networks
that's really funny
criticized from the left and mocked by
the right human cotton swab Anderson
Cooper tried to defend his Network's
decision to have Trump on I wonder who
was that man you were so upset to hear
from last night
that man you were so upset to hear from
last night he may be president of the
United States in less than two years and
that audience that upset you that's a
sampling of about half the country they
are your family members your neighbors
and they are voting and many said
they're voting for him
that man he who cannot be named
appearing on the network no one wants to
watch
even the dummies at CNN can't resist the
ratings gold of the orange man Cooper
was so shocked it turned his hair even
wider it's now wider than a neighborhood
watch in Martha's Vineyard
I wonder do you CNN viewers have every
right to be outraged and angry and never
watched the network again
you have every right to be outraged
today and angry never watched this
network again but do you think staying
in your Silo and only listening to
people you agree with is going to make
that person go away after last night
none of us can say I didn't know what's
out there I didn't know what's coming
I didn't know what's coming
yeah same thing they said about Jeffrey
tuben
never over never over
it does take a while you know never
forget remember never forget
he's a real hero here Brett is it me by
the way great job tonight with Kat on
Special Report yeah wow
we'll finally happened yeah it finally
happened
when when you guys got into that fight
over the debt ceiling I thought I
thought you were gonna leave get up and
leave well he almost did because you
were like you should be hosting you did
such a good job
it only took three years three years
three years uh listen when Anderson
Cooper says you have every right not to
watch the channel
you know everybody has the right they
have the clicker right they can change
the channel yeah the hand ringing has
really been something to watch hasn't it
no it is it's incredible it's as though
the last five years or so never existed
and this is all new to them and so what
they end up doing is they keep putting
their viewers through the same torture
because they really they're reliving the
experience without any progress it's
weird it's very strange it is very
strange I mean we went through some
rough times and then CNN said hey hold
my mocha yes they sure did I don't know
why I said mocha the CNN they don't
drink beer yeah it's true
well
they got a Bud Light or two
I'm not sure they drank it though yeah
Kennedy how are you wonderful thank you
excellent did you watch this town hall
and what were your thoughts and now how
do you feel about CNN's kind of reaction
no I had I had
to sending me clips and
sent a random clip that said she named
her cat vagina I'm like well that's all
you need
what it shows the reason they're so
upset is because Joe Biden can't do this
Joe Biden can't come to Fox and have a
town hall where he's he's confronted
with all of his failures and misdeeds
and conflicts of interest with his
family and God knows how many foreign
Nationals and different countries
because he would melt into a sad elderly
puddle right so that cannot happen it
would be great I mean I would love if
the president of the United States could
withstand something like that and you
could fill this entire audience with
Democrats it would be fine that's never
going to be happening that's never going
to happen and I think that's why they're
so upset because he they wouldn't be mad
if he lost if he was facial disgracialed
that would be a massive Victory that's
not what happened yeah there are also
Tyrus uh on CNN I don't know if you
could comment on this or not but they're
actually linking the the that town hall
to Russia saying that it was obvious
that Donald Trump was like influenced by
by Putin because he wouldn't call him a
war criminal it's like they still have
trumped Arrangement running through
their blood vessels one you know 24 7.
uh what's the scientific term for uh oh
uh
best night of TV that that network has
had in months right years years so since
Blackfish really yeah I I feel like this
is a plot this is like uh cat always
talks about the one friend who doesn't
really have a problem and will interrupt
you with like oh you won't believe what
happened to me I went to bed and I
forgot to plug in my cell phone for my
whole morning was completely screwed up
yeah what were you saying about fighting
cancer yes that's what CNN is doing
right they're pretending like there was
this who's up
am I missing something thing was their
protests outside mostly peaceful
protests outside the building was
Anderson followed to work by democrats
going how could you how could no one's
saying that they watched it to see Trump
the people who tuned in Saw Trump and
then they're going to go see Trump
wherever he goes they're not staying
with CNN right so what you saw last
night was the same thing they've been
seeing just say it yeah say it I get it
you had a marriage you got him to where
he needed to go he left you for a
younger woman and then he comes back
every so often and you let him in and
you let them have dinner you let them
spend the night and you wake up in the
morning and he leaves okay
it's your fault stop letting him in yes
okay
you know
cat
s
is the thing about like why are they
flipping out when nobody's mad do you
think they're doing this for the summer
you know the summer weekends on the
Hamptons so that people so that people
when they come after them and go why did
you have Trump on Anderson Cooper said
but you saw what I said please let me
have another Mimosa okay
okay first of all I would just like to
point out that my doorstep book has been
on the New York Times bestseller list
for three weeks in a row
so I would actually really like it to
make it a full month but that's not
going to be happening if you tell people
it's a doorstep it's a very good book
it's a great gift for your mom or if
your mom's Dead Like Mine buy it for
yourself
um I shouldn't work in marketing but
it's very good I'm very proud of it and
everyone should get it if they haven't
gotten it yet
um and I will say yes I agree with you
but I would also say it's of course
that's what they're doing because that's
what they've been doing right they see
Trump and they're like this is the end
of the country this is the end of the
Democracy they do that every time he
comes on the screen they probably didn't
even watch it they probably even know
what happened because that's what they
say but Kennedy is right people point
out oh it's so hard to interview Trump
because he steamrolls people but it's
actually would be harder I think to
interview Biden because he is so easily
steamrolled you could be like where are
you
yeah
that's too tough by the way we ask every
week every single week we've asked yeah
Town Hall interview whatever and I
finally said yes so that's right yes
there's hope yes there is President
Trump never steamrolled Brett Bear
no he's never afraid yeah we have an
interview soon oh that's good didn't
steamroll you no no no we had a lovely
dinner though afterwards we had the best
steak
look at these linens are amazing
everything at that place is the best you
know Brett does an incredible Trump
impression let me see it let me hear it
it's absolutely huge
[Applause]
oh we got more of Brett
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else